là monsieur rebonjour donc pour cette
édition spéciale après la disparition
tragique que la nuit dernière
disparition accidentelle de la princesse
lady diana 36 ans donc qui est morte à
paris dans un accident de voiture qui a
également tué son compagnon dodi al
fayed le fils d'un milliardaire égyptien
avec lequel elle vivait depuis quelques
semaines quelques mois voire maintenant
disparition également du chauffeur de la
voiture et le garde du corps a été trié
très grièvement blessé visiblement cet
accident a eu lieu alors que la voiture
était poursuivi par un certain nombre de
photographes de la presse à scandale les
paparazzi comme on dit en italien
l'accident a eu lieu je vous le rappelle
au beau milieu de la nuit sous le tunnel
du pont de l'alma à paris je vous
propose
avant d'aller plus loin d'entendre des
témoignages de voir comment maintenant
les choses vont se dérouler la suite des
événements donc et les conséquences sur
la monarchie britannique de nous
rappeler simplement en quelques minutes
les circonstances de l'accident pascal
golomer une carcasse littéralement broyé
l'état de la voiture témoigne de la
violence extrême du choc la puissante
mercedes était lancé à pleine vitesse
dans le tunnel de l'alma en plein paris
vers zéro heure trente sans doute plus
de 150 km pour une raison encore
inconnue
elle est venue heurter le mur puis l'un
des piliers du tunnel à son bord quatre
personnes
lady diana son ami dodi al fayed un
garde du corps et le chauffeur il venait
de quitter l'hôtel ritz place vendôme
pour fausser compagnie aux paparazzi qui
les suivaient à moto le chauffeur aurait
alors décidé de rouler très vite trop
vite
lorsque la police et les secours
arrivent sur place
dodi al fayed et le chauffeur sont déjà
décédés
la princesse de galles elle peut être
désincarcéré l'opération prend plus
d'une heure avant le transfert vers
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
pendant ce temps l'enquète débute cette
photographe sont rapidement emmené dans
les locaux de la brigade criminelle
les motos sont saisis comme pièces à
conviction peu avant 6 heures à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
les journalistes sont conviés
une conférence de presse improvisée
thoracotomie d'urgence a mis en évidence
qu'une plaie importante de la veine
pulmonaire gauche malgré la fermeture de
cette plaie et un massage cardiaque
externe et interne de djoser aucune
efficacité circulatoire n'a pu être
rétablie et le décès dé constater à 4
heures du matin j'adresse les
condoléances de la france à la famille
royale aux familles des victimes et au
peuple britannique tout entier lady
diana
c'était une personne très aimé en france
une femme moderne courageuse sensible à
la détresse humaine sa disparition sera
ressentie douloureusement dans notre
pays
quai des orfèvres les sept photographes
sont alors toujours interrogé par les
enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
le jour se lève les premiers parisien se
présente sous le tunnel de l'alma ou
rendre un dernier hommage à lady diana
princesse de galles
je vous le rappelle pour la